[Musique]
bienvenue sur ce plateau nous allons
donc quelques instants procédé à la
remise des prix du challenge airbus mba
change consacré à la défense et à la
sécurité qui est organisée dans le cadre
de tech'innove ira lui pris dans huit
catégories différentes et les robes et
en sang sont avec moi
laurent legendre bonjour bonjour vous
êtes directeur régional ile-de-france
d'airbus coupe développement et emmanuel
davy vous êtes technologie watch manager
à mbd à jean patrice alors va va
reparler dans quelques instants ce prix
que vous avez organisé il ya eu combien
je crois se voit une soixantaine de
morts il ya eu plus de 60 sociétés
candidates et nous en avons
présélectionné 36 et la grosse
difficulté était de retenir uniquement
huit candidats lauréats
sur ces 36 mais on va jouer on va y
revenir c'est bien difficile alors avant
d'avoir de parler du prix peut-être on
peut présenter chèque et chacune des
entreprises d'abord un airbus groupe
développement et en bus développement
est l'entité qui accompagnent les start
up pour le groupe et nous sommes
une autre une entreprise qui travaille
pour l'ensemble des divisions d'airbus
et des filiales quand même baie des ha
d'où l'organisation de ce groupe mais
comme vous le pouvez le voir airbus
c'est aussi un acteur majeur dans le
domaine de la défense avec l'eurofighter
que vous voyez ici l'a400m les avions
ravitailleurs donc beaucoup de
programmes et surtout des programmes
futurs comme le scaf le futur chasseur
du futur qui va être un programme commun
avec un bda qui vais travailler aussi là
dessus et sur lequel on a besoin
d'innovation et c'est pour ça qu'on a
décidé de lancer ce challenge open
innovation défense en collaboration
entre airbus ds et mba et donc emmanuel
lévy mbd ah oui bonjour donc emmanuel
lévy oui donc je suis responsable
technologie watch donc au sein des
directions d'innovation et d'une
technologie de même les drm bda est un
groupe de défense en leader européen dé
des missiles et de systèmes de domicile
comme vous pourrez le voir sur la vidéo
mais quelles sont nos enjeux ont
finalement pourquoi nous sommes là
aujourd'hui dans un monde de plus en
plus interconnecté ans avec des menaces
évoluant rapidement et mme bédard en
force maîtrise des effets et investit
dans de nouveaux types d'effets de
nouvelles technologies et leur mode
d'emploi associés pour développer une
nouvelle génération d'armement et
d'effecteur pour vous donner un exemple
dans la dans la lutte anti drones notre
offre modulaire skyward 'on peut
associer alors pour la neutralisation en
plus des effets cinétiques du brouillage
ou des arts ménagers diriger pour les
censeurs différents types de radars ou
de censure passif pour le centre de
contrôle
un logiciel modulaire et des algorithmes
avec de l'intelligence artificielle pour
être plus rapide et plus précis dans ce
contexte le recours à des acteurs
innovants ici deux issues des pme et des
startups comme on va voir et critiquant
pour accéder à des compétences et des
idées hors champ du coeur business
historique de nba qu'est-ce que c'est
une sorte de course poursuite faut entre
autres les uns
et à coeur enfin les réseaux qui seront
qui attaque et puis et puis la défense
et c'est de plus en plus important de
travailler dans ce domaine là parce que
quand on va avoir un système de guidage
de missiles interconnecté avec
l'électronique de les chasseurs qui
envoie le missile les liaisons au sol
s'il y en a que si un hacker arrive à
rentrer dans le système qui peut mettre
tout au tapis et donc il faut trouver de
nouvelles solutions qui viendront
probablement de l'informatique quantique
pour être toujours à la pointe avec
toujours un cran en avance par rapport à
l'ennemi à la menace cfrt général parce
que pluton s'informatise plus il ya de
risques et en même temps plusieurs de
riposte possible conversion par un peu
de ce challenge de ce prix c'est ça il
avait dit elle ça permet aux start-up et
aux pme innovantes de présenter leurs
créations
alors on se dit quand même et des
start-ups et des petites des petites
structures d'aidé grosses machines comme
airbus par exemple ça les intéresse
quand cela vous intéresse quand même là
leur création bien sûr en fait la
différence entre un grand groupe comme
airbus qui est capable de déployer un
programme un grand programme pour
réaliser un a400m ou un avion de ligne
on a un petit peu moins d'agilité quand
il s'agit d'aller investiguer de
nouvelles technologies émergentes et là
justement on va pouvoir s'appuyer sur
des start up qui l on voit aller
beaucoup plus vite dans ce domaine là
ils vont prendre la place sur ce terrain
là et va nous permettre de nous
introduire en faisant des preuves de
concept
ces technologies plus rapidement dans
nos produits et après il y aura toute
une phase de validation
d'industrialisation qui elle va être
plus longue
ils ont beaucoup de fiabilité mais ça
c'est notre métier on sait le faire
par contre on peut gagner du temps sur
la phase d'innovation grâce à la
rapidité et l'agilité de ses start up on
peut dire que aimé de les vics vous
faussez start-up répondent déjà aux
besoins du futur
oui nous sommes dans sa maison déjà
fallu près de leur futur va très vite
présent votre ellison mais surtout
aujourd'hui je pensais au futur
c'est très important nous sommes dans un
monde on a une accélération des
technologies sont les technologies
peuvent venir de partout des pme des
start up des labos de différents
secteurs etc c'est notre travail donc de
rester au courant donc d'avoir cette
politique de veille technologique et des
outils pour soutenir les pme et les
start up
alors on va voir évidemment les prix
correct été retenu mais d'une façon
générale vous avez été impressionnée
injustement l'inventivité de 2 c de ces
startups oui oui tout à fait on a
rencontré des choses très intéressantes
très innovante alors il ya les huit
qu'on va présenter mi en a plein
d'autres qu'on n'a pas que maintenir
retenir que oui lauréat mais en fait on
a même trouvé des start up qui viennent
d'autres domaines de filières qui sont
pas des filières de la défense a priori
mais qui ont des technologies qui
peuvent s'appliquer dans la défense et
c'est ça qui est intéressant avec ce
salon tech innove c'est justement il ya
ce brassage qui permet de faire
éclore des techno qui viennent d'une
autre filière dans la filière défense
juste un mot parce qu'on a mené veut
parler quand on est la risée prix de
tech'innove c'est vrai que la situation
sanitaire complique un peu les choses
aujourd'hui mais vous avez répondu
différemment avec beaucoup de succès est
ce que pour le pour le salon airbus
avait déjà opposé le même problème où
c'était plus simple à résoudre
non parce que le salon tech'innove s'est
organisée c'est de façon à travailler en
distance yale et donc il ya eu cette
journée du 1er avril là où et près de
7000 rendez vous qui se sont organisés
qui était fabuleuse et qu'on a qu'on a
clôt sur ce même plateau
et puis pendant le toute la durée du
mois de on a eu ces candidatures qui
nous sont arrivées
et 60 candidatures ç'a dépassé nos
espoirs et la capacité qu'on avait
organisé les régions basculent
on avait les étudier les dossiers on a
dû faire 3 3 sessions de sélection donc
on a retenu pour chaque session une
douzaine d'entreprises mais il a fallu
présélectionnés et donc ça a été très
enrichissant d'avoir un mois complet
pour pouvoir organiser ce challenge avec
et faire face à l'afflux de candidatures
donc c'était finalement pas gênant
d'être dans en mode distant ciel les
outils utilisés par le salon tech'innove
était tout à fait pertinent et nous ont
permis de rencontrer toutes les
entreprises et de faire les choix en
ayant une présentation des projets que
les chacune de ces entreprises nous
proposait de les vivre l'été quelque
chose sur ses sept sélections et ses
choix oui on avait demandé effectivement
aux entreprises non seulement de
candidates et de se présenter mais aussi
de proposer un projet pour pour la
défense ou la sécurité ont pour airbus
ou au mba et on a été impressionné par
la qualité des réponses finale aussi le
sérieux qui a été mis dans ces
candidatures donc on a eu de très belles
candidatures de très beaux projets dont
qu'il soit été très difficile
raison de plus pour glorifier ceux qui
ont été retenus
si vous avez d'accord on va on va passer
à la remise de ces huit pris dans huit
catégories différentes et on va
commencer par la première catégorie qui
est communication intelligence et
sécurité
[Musique]
leur le rôle aux jantes c'est à vous
qu'il va revenir de remettre afin de
donner le nom du gagnant et on va pas
les faire attendre plus longtemps donc
pour cette catégorie geipel la société
quick networks et je vais proposer à
monsieur arnaud vieux de nous raconter
un petit peu ce qui nous a proposé la
son nouveau routeur de nouvelle
génération qui nous permet d'avoir plus
de débit et de sécurité
arnaud dieu est avec nous bonjour merci
alors très rapidement effectivement la
société d'economie torse éditeurs de
logiciels a conçu et mis sur le marché
en hauteur et ceux des one très
performant qui s'appelle le one rover
alors c'est un socle technologique
innovant nous sommes d'ailleurs très
heureux que le jury du challenge open
innovation porté par airbus
développement et mbd à nous est
récompensée et de ce fait reconnaissent
notre position d'entreprise innovante
dans le domaine de la sécurité des
télécommunications reconnaissance
d'autant plus importante car elle
souligne notre choix d'avoir entièrement
écrits de zéro notre logiciel est donc
d'être complètement souverain quant à la
propriété de notre coq ça c'est très
important
reconnaissance aussi le positionnement
atypique un entreprise qui fait rien
comme les autres et qui innovent jusque
dans sa structure et son financement
mais je tenais d'ailleurs à nos 70
actionnaires qui sont peut-être à
l'écran qui me regardent qui nous
soutiennent indéfectiblement dans notre
projet depuis plusieurs années alors je
voudrais aussi faire un salut tout
particulier en ce moment en cette
période à william technique qui est
l'inventeur et concepteur de la
technologie qui est récompensée
aujourd'hui est un grand merci aux
équipes qui nous ont permis de mettre le
moindre revers sur le marché et d'avoir
un produit opérationnel qui souvent
alors que phénomène rover et à quoi
sert-il loin de rovers d'un module
hybride multi liens permettant
l'agrégation contrôle et de liaison
réseau hétérogène afin d'augmenter la
capacité de bout en bout alors
l'agrégation c'est essentiel pour tous
les utilisateurs qui ont assez des micro
coupures pendant leur visioconférence
leurs appels téléphoniques ou pendant la
diffusion leur événement sur internet le
one rover c'est la garantie qu'un
usagers du tgv n'aura pas de coupure de
la connexion wifi pendant son trajet
idem pour le passager d'un vol
transatlantique sa connexion ne sera
plus interrompu car tous les liens
disponibles
mis à contribution en même temps alors
le moindre revers comme je dis c'est un
socle technologique qui se base sur une
parfaite isolation mémoire sa capacité
d'isolation exceptionnellement fait un
excellent bac à sable pour lutter contre
les ventes sur les rangs de somewhere
par exemple les îles isolées où vit en
toute sécurité les slides ce 5 g en
trombe sur un même équipement
tout comme me lizonne les uns des autres
les différents liens de communication
d'un avion la cabine le cockpit des
instruments de vol les données
constructeur et plus encore alors le
gone rover c'est une innovation mondiale
qui peut améliorer des usages en de très
très nombreux marchés à très forte
valeur ajoutée
et voilà je voudrais vraiment quand vous
remercier de nous avoir récompensé
s'exprime très fier et très content
merci on voit que ça que vous êtes
satisfait de ça va du passager du tgv
aux entreprises évidemment oui il ya des
applications pour la défense aussi et
dont la défense a su attendre dans nos
vieux sur sur technique network vous
disiez c'est ici qu'une c'est une
entreprise qui a un qui est des cons
alors t'es quoi qu'il en soit l'une en
2015 2015 et vous êtes combien de
personnes qui travaillaient à trois amis
un moment droit et avec un financement
particulier c'est à dire vous venez au
dirham au financement en fait il est
intégralement en l'homme modeste à dire
que ce ne sont que des actionnaires des
particuliers des des personnes qu'on a
rencontrés ou faire un genre de
développement qui nous ont soutenus et
qui continuent à nous soutenir
aujourd'hui qui sont très contentes de
notre de notre fonctionnement et là on
en est et à 77 actionnaires
officiellement dans l'est dans les
livres mais on en a déjà des nouveaux
qui sont en train d'arriver
donc ça bien voilà c'est vraiment un
très atypique
bravo vous avez une question à poser
dans oui je crois que vous êtes aussi en
discussion avec airbus pour pour un
projet vous pouvait on dire de quelqu'un
oui oui absolument vous permettrai pas
de dévoiler trop d'informations hâtives
et ils vont d'abord à thouars d'airbus
très très avancé dans un des sujets dont
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure
et qu'il la liaison avec la vie oui on
va dire avec tout ce qui va autour
d'elle dans son environnement d'autres
avions des satellites et bateaux l'un
des rares etc
l avantage du moindre over sait qu'il
est capable ou utilisent donc ça
intéresse beaucoup l'équipe de texte
pour ne pas la citer votre votre siège
lé tout alors le siège est à saint
thibéry dans l'hérault nous sommes
hébergés par une pépinière qui s'appelle
giga med explore et nous sommes un peu
tendance dans un lieu situé proche de
entre pézenas et le cap d'agde pas
désagréable qu'on a dit on a des bureaux
sis à rueil malmaison né en héberger par
ailleurs par des actionnaires qui nous
héberge 30 ans vient en région
parisienne côté bravo donc c'était de le
prix communication intelligente sécurité
et c'est d'entreprise networks qui le
remporte
merci merci infiniment arnaud vieux et
et bravo libre à vous c'est formidable
enfin vous le voir je pense à tout au
long de cet après midi mais voilà ils
sont trois salariés rien n'a filtré
nouveau il ya une action créativité
formidable dans tout l'est dans tous les
sens quoi dans tous les points de vue et
des innovations importantes
il a peut-être pas beaucoup développée
mais ils ont créé un opéra team system
souverain c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
besoin de de l'operating system de
microsoft ou
ont déjà leurs auteurs fonctionne avec
son propre os
alors on va passer au 2e 2e prix c'est
la catégorie communication sécurisé et
terrestres emmanuel lévy c'est à vous
d'annoncer le gagnant le plaisir
d'annoncer l'entreprise primés et al
ciom donc pour son projet de radios
logicielles performantes et adaptable à
chaque bande de fréquences et donc
j'appelle monsieur robert lacoste
fondateur et monsieur thomas des barn
directeur général nous acceptions
lacoste qui est avec nous bonjour
bonjour bonjour à tous savoir écouter
très heureux d'être parmi vous merci
beaucoup d'organisateurs bien sûr et aux
sponsors de l'événement on est on est
bien sûr puisque ravi d'être voilà et
puisque rami d'être d'être sélectionné
deux mots peut-être pour représenter
déjà le ciom après je prendrai un petit
peu de donc mon et j'allais j'allais
dire qu'on est une petite entreprise
mais par rapport à ce que dira renom une
grande entreprise de dix personnes
basées donc à viroflay dans les yvelines
et notre notre métier c'est la recherche
et développement en électronique
alors on est aussi atypique comme commis
arnaud merci d'être là boîtier premiers
mots d'un typique sur deux aspects sur
l'aspect technique parce qu'on entre
dans notre métier en électronique
on est particulièrement spécialisée dans
un domaine qui est un peu perçu comme de
la magie noire par beaucoup c'est le
domaine des communications s'en fout
donc ça me positionne dans un rôle un
peu particulier dans le domaine de
l'électronique et une autre
particularité c'est que nos clients sont
extrêmement variés on a à peu près la
moitié de nos clients qui sont eux-mêmes
des start up ou des pme qui font appel à
nous pour les aider quelque part à
transformer leurs rêves vos produits ou
pour les aider à franchir une étape
technologique et l'autre moitié de nos
clients ses services et média cd grands
comptes qui font appel à nous attendre à
des grands comptes
côté direction innovation et qui nous
font d'intervenir pour les aider à
imaginer ou à faire des démonstrateurs
des technologies d'après demain notre
notre métier
alors dans ce contexte là on a présenté
un projet qu'on a baptisé le dr film il
alors qui est en projet dans le domaine
des radios logicielles c'est un terme un
peu barbare un grosso modo une radio
logicielle c'est d'utiliser calcul à la
place de composants électroniques pour
faire les communications sans fil de
manière extrêmement flexible avec de
meilleures performances
ah ça c'est la bonne nouvelle la
mauvaise nouvelle c'est que l'arrêt de
logiciels c'est un truc un peu compliqué
il ya eu pas mal de déboires parce que
ça nécessite une très très grande curie
six pénalités dans les équipes pour
arriver à faire quelque chose qui marche
et notre notre notre idée notre
proposition a été de développer un
module à une brique technologique qui
quelque part en capsules cette
complexité et permet à de mettre à
disposition cette technologie de radio
logicielle pour plein d'applications et
en particulier pour des applications de
sécurité de défense
on peut parler de communications
sécurisées mais aussi de surveillance du
spectre par exemple ont détecté des et
des choses pas normales
c'est une technologie bien sûr 100%
conscient france à 100% fabriqué en
france a ramené à ces pierres donc
donc voilà on espère que cet événement
va nous permettre de le démultiplier les
applications de cette belle nouvelle
technologie de l'évident fait poser de
questions sur ce nom est ce que c'est ce
que vous voulez piété plus concrètement
parler de l'utilité de cette de cette
découverte et de ce produit approche
radio logicielle de manière générale le
gros avantage que ça si vous prenez je
ne sais pas votre téléphone portable il
sait écouter des bandes et radio
cellulaire mais il sait faire que ça
si vous prenez votre réseau votre
téléphone votre radio réveil c'est
écouter la radio fm une se faire que ça
une radio logicielle le gros avantage
c'est qu'on peut simplement en changeant
sans logiciel comme vous mettriez à jour
votre ordinateur lui faire traiter
n'importe quel type de signaux et donc
être adaptable à n'importe quoi c'est ça
le gros avantage à ce genre de
technologie et pour des communications
sécurisées ça permet par exemple de
changer de mode de communication de
changer de fréquence de changer de ce
qu'on veut quasiment instantanément et
en fonction des besoins
c'est une très très grande flexibilité
dans le genre
forces de sécurité qui sont clientes
d'airbus pour la radio mobiles
professionnelles les terminaux que les
policiers utilisent tous les jours il ya
une évolution qui va aller vers des
systèmes qui vont être digitaux vers ce
qu'on appelle le lt eux c'est du 5 g
sécurisées et il va falloir concevoir
des systèmes hybrides qui fonctionnent
avec les anciens terminé parce que la
police n'aura pas les moyens de tout
changer d'un seul coup et avec de
nouvelles technologies et c'est là que
cette technologie sont intéressantes et
un mot robert lacoste l ciom vous disiez
c'est vous ne vous en êtes le fondateur
vous l'avez quel était l'objet
l'objectif que vous avez créé cette
entreprise
ensuite c'était vraiment de alors je
vais être très franc avec vous le
premier objectif a été de me faire
plaisir à titre personnel c'est à dire
que les dans de grandes entreprises je
faisais des projets les fantastiques
très impressionnant mais j'étais un
petit peu moins de technique est une
personnelle et j'ai voulu remettre
l'expertisé technique au centre de ma
vie est constituée autour de tour des
autres mois dans mamma lucia sommes une
équipe de d'experts qui qui non
seulement apporter des solutions à leurs
clients mais aussi ils prennent du
plaisir
voilà c'est un petit peu le type et à
destination donc on a compris c'était
une grosse entreprise à côté de
technique mais ça reste une start-up
célibat est bien coté bravo bravo pour
cette pour ce que vous êtes radio
logicielle et pour pourra le ciom et
pour ce prix bien mérité
très bien mérité merci infiniment robert
lacoste
alors on va passer à la troisième
catégorie cela qu torride catégorie
drones
et là c'est vous laurent legendre qui
revêtait ce prix j'y vais appeler la
start up drones et je vais pas la faire
attendre plus il s'agit d' hyperion
seven et monsieur olivier nière vous
allez nous expliquer un petit peu parce
qu on vous connaissait au départ pour
des drones filaire qui servait dans
l'événementiel pour le sport et
expliquez nous un peu maintenant ce que
vous pouvez nous proposer dans le
domaine de la défense avec vos drones
bonjour tout d'abord c'est un immense
plaisir d'être ici même une fierté
d'avoir remporté ce challenge pour toute
l'équipe donc nous on est aussi une
petite équipe l'issue de la passion au
départ de cette passionnée du rugby et
si on notre premier projet était partir
sur de la captation sportive et sur
l'idée qu'on allait apporter un angle
différent à tout ce qui est le modèle
sportif et tout ce qu'on peut regarder
autour principalement du rugby mais
aussi du foot du ski on a on a pas mal
évolué aussi sur les chevaux et c'est le
sait la dgs et la direction générale de
l'aviation civile qui nous a dit mais
vous rendez pas qu'on avait vraiment
quelque chose qui a une vraie valeur
ajoutée dans le domaine de la sécurité
et vous devriez vous orienter sur ce
marché le reste c'est bien pour vous
marrez entre vous mais quand même le
vrai marché il nous semble être beaucoup
plus sur cet aspect là donc fort de
cette collaboration et cette relation
qu'on avait très forte avec la dgs est
depuis l'origine de notre projet qui est
nous on est une petite équipe de sept
associés et on a embarqué avec nous des
jeunes et des jeunes ingénieurs qui nous
ont rejoints de différentes écoles et on
est super heureux pour eux parce que ces
pépites ses talents ils vont pouvoir
collaborer avec des experts de mba et
des experts deux airbus et c'est le plus
beau cadeau qu'on pouvait leur faire
donc au delà de l'accélération que ça
représente pour notre projet c'est un
vrai beau challenge et une vraie belle
aventure qui démarre avec une bd à
airbus et donc la particularité ici sur
la partie sécurité
c'est vraiment l'idée d'avoir un droit
nous y perd sécurisé qui est une
association d'innovation à lui tout seul
sur les différentes éléments qui le
composent avec un brevet qui est l'objet
volant qui ne tombe jamais et donc ce
qu'il ya derrière c'est un relais d'un
câble qui à la fois une alimentation à
une fibre optique qui fait que notre
drones ne peut pas être hacker qui peut
traiter des données et des données très
importantes en instantané en faisant en
rapatriant au sol ce que nos capteurs
peuvent mettre en place et notamment le
fait d'avoir un drone multi capteurs
capables d'embarquer des capteurs
optiques sonic chimiques qui discutent
entre eux et qu'ils discutent avec une
une base environnementale et ce qui
permet de pouvoir travailler sur des
sites sensibles où il n'y a pas ce
risque de chute sur sur des de tout ce
qui peut être dans deux mondes
pétrochimique par exemple ou nucléaires
et puis aussi ce qui était vraiment
notre projet ici parce qu'on a essayé de
répondre complètement grâce à vincent
chevalier qui est un des membres du
centre d'expertisé des programmes navale
la capacité à adosser notre système sur
un navire et sur le fait de pouvoir à la
fois fonctionné comme un relais de
télécommunications comme une
identification via capteur optique des
mines ou de naufragés qu'on retrouverait
au niveau de la mer et puis aussi tout
ce qui est la spécialité de dinde aux
deux laboratoires parce qu'on est issu
de vignes et de deux laboratoires de
l'université de lyon d'un côté lgl en
géologie de l'autre côté elvis en
innovation dans le sport et donc c'est
l'idée vraiment d'apporter toute cette
innovation au service de la sécurité et
y compris du domaine spectral de
l'analyse de l'eau et de tout ce qui est
aussi l'analyse de la pop et de la
pollution au niveau 2 des côtes
voilà ce qui est notre joli projet et je
le répète on est super heureux vraiment
de rentrer dans cette collaboration avec
laurent legendre et avec emmanuel lévy
bravo c'est tout à fait couper ce vote
est exposé aux divines hier on avait eu
la joie de vous recevoir lors de la
remise des prix de techni neuf sur ce
sur ce plateau et voilà
on va se donner rendez vous tous les
mois vous ne parlerez comme ça on n'est
pas certaine avec grand corps merci
infiniment et bravo on va passer à la 4e
catégorie c la cavalerie de
l'intelligence artificielle
[Musique]
et c'est pour vous aimez mieux de vie un
beau sujet de série compliquée vais me
bouffait pas faire trop patienter les
les candidats donc le gagnant et d'el
fox avec son projet de système autonome
de contrôle d'un essaim de drone aérien
et donc j'invite alice même en 6e à nous
rejoindre
et voilà la liste mais moqué la bonjour
et bravo bonjour bonjour à tous qu'on
soit monsieur le chantre bonjour
monsieur lévy merci infiniment pour ce
prix merci à tous les membres du jury
qui a qui ont voté pour des accès qui
ont vraiment retenu à à cette
proposition qu'on a fait
ce prix vient réellement consolider le
positionnement stratégique de dalles fox
par rapport donc à une technologie bien
spécifique de la de l'intelligence
artificielle qui est l'apprentissage
pour renforcement c'est une technologie
de rupture et surtout un pari sur
l'avenir que dalle fox prend puisque
c'est la technologie fondatrice de nos
solutions qui pour nous va permettre au
robot de réfléchir à nous travaillons
réellement sur cette technologie depuis
bientôt trois ans est notre objectif
c'est réellement de proposer à travers
une plateforme la première solution
d'autonomie décisionnel pour les
systèmes industriels et de défense
l'enjeu est de permettre à nos clients
donc ils sont des industriels mais aussi
des institutionnels de modéliser eux
mêmes des systèmes qui seront capables
d'évoluer intelligemment et
dynamiquement dans un environnement
changeant
il faut préciser ici que une fois que
les systèmes sont modélisés dans des
environnements de simulation la promesse
de nos solutions c'est réellement de les
porter sur des plateformes physiques sur
des vecteurs physique et de les mettre
en condition de missions opérationnelles
on a eu le plaisir est d'ailleurs
l'opportunité en tant que lauréat du pea
mmt inquiète un programme de défense
amont à d'appliquer sur ces technologies
sur des problématiques de gestion de
missions
on a eu l'opportunité de collaborer avec
des acteurs pour dassault thales notre
objectif aujourd'hui c'est vraiment de
consolider notre position
demant surtout le marché tout le secteur
de l'aérospatiale défend c'est
d'ailleurs dans ce sens on est
particulièrement fière de collaborer à
d'avoir ce prix pardon et donc de
pouvoir collaborer avec m bda et à
airbus par rapport à l'accélération qui
va suivre pour donner un petit aperçu
donc de kidal fox mousser à hsinchu une
start up qui a été créée donc en février
on est basée à bordeaux c'est à peu près
une quinzaine de personnes a
majoritairement donc des ingénieurs et
des docteurs qui sont réellement
passionné d'intelligence artificielle et
qui contribuent réellement à défier a
poussé les limites de cette technologie
et à proposer des solutions qui sont
réellement concrète qui résolvent
réellement des problématiques concrètes
les complexes a donc voilà donc je
partage avec eux ce moment et je leur
dédie à ce prix donc voilà basée à
bordeaux accompagne également par cette
ardeur ce qui nous soutient réellement
dans notre croissance et donc je
mettrais un petit mot sur voilà sur nos
perspectives puisque actuellement nous
recrutons pour pour consolider ce
développement ce positionnement est à et
continuer de croître
merci beaucoup merci et bravo à emmanuel
davis important au plus alors voilà
c'est des autres faits ce qui marque qui
embauchent
ils sont sûrs d'eux des sujets dans le
dans les grandes tendances ans je sais
pas s'ils sont pas une minute de plus
pour en dire un peu plus sur
l'apprentissage par renforcement mais ça
c'est un grand sujet du moment
oui effectivement cessé c'est le très
très grands sujets du moment puisque
c'est un sujet qui va vraiment venir
pousser un peu plus loin les
technologies puisque par rapport aux
technologies traditionnelles à qui ont
une approche un peu plus limité dans la
mesure où pour une action il ya une
série à d'instruction défini l'avantagé
l'apprentissage par renforcement c'est
vraiment de laisser jean leader le libre
arbitre à aux algorithmes qui vont
apprendre de leurs expériences et donc
s'appuyer à sur soi des erreurs et avoir
des pénalités ou alors des succès y
avoir des récompenses n'est donc sûr
qu'ils vont avoir des comportements qui
leur permet d'avoir des récompenses bas
ils vont effectivement innover et
proposer des solutions qui sont de plus
plus performante pour pour l'industriel
qui est qui posent une problématique
absolument extraordinaire
merci merci beaucoup les mémos bravo
bravo donc à del fox et on va passer à
la cinquième catégorie kilos là aussi
une catégorie d'actualité s'il en est
puisqu'il s'agit de la cyber sécurité
[Musique]
le rôle au gendre c'est à vous la
cybersécurité s'éteint c'est un métier
d'airbus mais on est toujours à la
recherche de nouvelles technologies et
cette fois ci on veut récompenser la
société halliburton et je vais demander
à monsieur jérôme à en prendre de venir
nous raconter un peu ce que fait elle
godden qui est un acteur du edge
computing avec c'est une nouvelle
génération de boîtes noires
transactionnel bonjour bonjour à tous
alors je suis désolé je suis stuff
ballon on parle directeur d'algues
automne les pages et groupes de
directeur commercial alors c'est ça qui
n'a finalement pas pu se joindre au
dernier moment
donc merci airbus merci m bda de nous
avoir sélectionné sur ce challenge
tech'innove 2021 et merci à chacun de
m'accueillir chez vous à distance je
donne c'est une société de cybersécurité
nous sommes basés à montpellier créé en
comme vous le savez les objets connectés
sont partout et la sécurité des objets
est l'un des enjeux majeurs de leur
utilisation
i'll go donne propose une plate forme de
sécurité matérielle clés en main pour
gérer ces réseaux d'objets connectés
avec une sécurité de bout en bout
jusqu'à l'intérieur même de l'objet est
donc au-delà de la seule sécurisation de
la communication dans nos solutions
concernent les objecté à forte valeur
ajoutée soit parce qu'ils évoluent en
milieu hostile
ou bien parce qu'ils ont des forces en
jeu financier et que des attaques à
distance ou des attaques physiques
peuvent s'avérer dramatique
nos solutions garantissent aussi le
contrôle d'usagé et la remontée
d'informations sécurisés de chaque objet
ce qui fait que on est aussi dans ce
qu'on appelle la maintenance prédictive
ou maintenance prévisionnel puisqu'on
peut donc remonter ces informations pour
les mesurer et faire du paiement à usage
aujourd'hui nous nous considérons comme
une société duale c'est-à-dire agissant
dans les secteurs civil et militaire
et finalement comme nous sécurisons
n'importe quel électroniques de ces
objets nos cas d'application sont assez
vastes ont des dents cloud
on est sur la sécurisation de
trottinette en libre-service on peut
être utilisée sur des robots on peut
être utilisée sur des drones on pourrait
même à l'avenir être utilisée sur des
automobiles puisque c'est un des grands
enjeux de l'automobile du futur la
sécurisation du véhicule autonome sur ce
challenge précisément nous proposons
développer un composant électronique qui
est un module matériel de sécurité
souverain ce qui est important pour les
acteurs de la défense qui utiliserait
nos technologies pour s'interposer sur
des dispositifs de stockage de type
disque dur donc les principes de son
composant ont déjà été discutés avec des
industriels de la défense mais on peut
évidemment envisager des applications
civiles
alors de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit de
stocker avec la maîtrise de la sécurité
par là l'utilisateur c'est à dire des
clés de chiffrement par exemple des
informations critiques d'usagé de
maintenance ou de communication en fait
toutes les informations que vous ne
souhaitez pas qu'une personne tierce
puisse voir donc ce composant en
s'appuierait sur des circuits
programmables et surtout sur les
technologies algo donne pour renforcer
la sécurité non seulement en production
mais tout au long du cycle des usages
notre objectif serait d'avoir un premier
pilote au prototype sur 2021 et donc
d'avoir gagné ce challenge est une
grosse aide pour nous et je remercie
encore tous le jury de tech'innove de
nous avoir choisis
merci beaucoup et christophe ballon
c'est vrai que c'est un enjeu essentiel
oui la cybersécurité on le voit tous les
jours est un enjeu majeur
dans tous les domaines que ce soit les
domaines liés à la défense ou la ctc
critique mais même pour le civil on
parlait tout à l'heure des problèmes de
hacking des hôpitaux récemment il faut
développer de nouvelles solutions qui
vont aller sécuriser plus vite les
technologies dans tous les domaines et
surtout éviter de perdre la bataille par
rapport aux hackers qui essaient tu peux
aussi d'avoir un coup d'avancé
c'est toujours c'est toujours cette
course poursuite et bravo dockal godden
d'avoir d'avoir votre votre invention
est d'avoir remporté ce prix merci
beaucoup
christophe vallon merci avant alors on
va passer à la catégorie suivante c'est
la catégorie équipements spatiaux
[Musique]
et c'est avoue emmanuel lévy et oui le
spatial on a aussi des bruits de plus en
plus d'intelligence dans les systèmes de
l'entreprise gagnante et staff pour la
convergence des jumeaux numérique pour
les parties physiques afin d'assurer la
sécurité des systèmes embarqués mobile
donc j'appelle adriana gonelle coq et
fondatrice et co fondatrice de stats ans
bonjour a brillé dans l'agglo donnell
bonjour merci beaucoup pour ce prix qui
nous honore et qui va nous aider à sur
notre chemin pour imposer la technologie
disruptive que nous avons conçu dans le
street
l'industrie des systèmes embarqués
critiques dans le but de résoudre le
problème de sûreté liés à l'usagé des
processeurs à plusieurs coeurs pour
décrire ce natif en quelques mots nous
sommes bilan qui ne rien à créer un 2019
pour tracer une technologie brevetée
vers l'industrie l'idée du salat de se
lasser nous appartient à liliana coup
grosjean cofondatrice et à moi même
sachant que la vision la connaissance du
domaine et le comment c'est elle qui
nous les a soufflé à tous les membres de
l'équipe
nous sommes sept aujourd'hui des experts
âge architectures de processeurs et en
statistiques
je peux dire que notre équipe et notre
plus grande richesse
d'ailleurs un grand merci à eux pour
leur dévouement et leur enthousiasme
notre expertise et l'estimation du
comportement temporelle des programmes
sachant que la robustesse de cette
estimation est la base même du
fonctionnement d'un système embarqué en
étant ensemble des méthodes
d'optimisation temps réel des méthodes
statistiques nous arrivons nous
seulement à rendre prédictible le
comportement dans l'ensemble des
programmes ce relent porte qui est le
type de processeur mais nous le faisons
tout en réduisant le site des
développements et en réduisant la
consommation d'énergie
nous sommes en cubes et agoras noces
accompagné par l'accélérateur wilko et
nous venons également d'intégrer la
seule incubateur déshabille nous nous
orientons aujourd'hui surtout vers le
marché de l'aérospatiale qui peut
profiter de plusieurs fonctionnalités de
notre technologie estimé le bilan
d'exécution des programmes configure l
architecture des processeurs pour faire
la couverture de comptes gérés les
interférences entre le programme réduire
la consommation d'énergie
nous travaillons déjà avec l'image de
véhicules autonomes avec airbus
avio ni avec ce temps les robotics et
commençons prochainement à travailler
avec un constructeur de l'ansat et les
voilà tous statique nouveau roma si on
nous remercions les membres du jury pour
ce prix on nous avons hâte de découvrir
le problématique
r space se défend c'est peut-être une
question est ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
est un discret tout me direz si vous
essayez la discrète ouvrait pour des
pavés petit plaisir accents vous venez
d'où est votre co fondatrice appelle les
lianes à vous et adriers là c'est une
coïncidence nous sommes originaires de
roumanie d'accord et vous évoque le
siège de votre 2 tfc ou encore très bien
vous avez voulu ajouter quelque chose
non c'est un bon exemple aussi de
technologies transverses en voix qui a
été beaucoup d'application et j'ai dû
logiquement on va dire ça va ça nous
intéresse aussi côté côté défense puis
c'est une preuve on a eu tout à l'heure
alice mais mangue
on a on a brillé dans google est qu il
ya aussi des femmes mandole danser c'est
un tapez cdc dans mais c'est important
de souligner que malheureusement et
heureusement
merci beaucoup et bravo et bravo
on va passer la nouvelle catégorie c la
surveillance maritime
[Musique]
et le prix est remis par laurent
legendre
alors pour cette catégorie ce
surveillance maritime je vais demander
s'ils proviennent de nous expliquer
j'appellerai monsieur antoine thébaux ce
qu'on peut faire en surveillance
maritime avec un espèce de réseaux de
drones de des maires qui ont peuvent
avoir des applications civiles mais
aussi dual en s'orientant vers vers la
défense et bientôt de dégoût et la bon
jour bonjour à tous merci beaucoup déjà
de cette opportunité de présenter six
provinces et puis très très content
aussi de ce prix forcément alors pour
présenter s'ils proviennent nous on est
en effet dans le domaine du maritime et
plus précisément de la collecte de
données en mer faut savoir que la france
forcément un territoire maritime très
très vaste c'est le deuxième plus grand
territoire maritime du monde et donc il
ya des enjeux liés à ces territoires qui
sont assez colossaux et pour répondre à
ces enjeux on a besoin de nouveaux
outils nouveaux outils qui vont
permettre deux choses 1 ce qu'on appelle
le monitoring des océans donc c'est
permettre de mieux connaître finalement
les océans sur des paramètres divers
évalué divers et variés typiquement
mesures et des changements climatiques
mesures et des produits on peut
retrouver en mer mesurer des paramètres
physico chimique de l'eau me dirai tout
un tas d'éléments qui vont nous
permettre de mieux comprendre finalement
ce qui se passe dans l'océan et puis un
deuxième aspect qui nous intéresse plus
aujourd'hui qui est l'aspect
surveillance maritime a et c'est là que
nous on intervient aussi ce qu'on a
développé ce sont des navires autonome a
donc ce sont des navires sans équipage
navires qui font vingtaine de mètres de
long sans équipage complètement
électrique et qui vont permettre
justement de rester très longtemps en
mer plusieurs mois en mer pour collecter
des données donc on va on les compare
maintenant un petit peu à des satellites
de la mer c'est à dire que ce sont des
navires qui vont être bourré de capteurs
divers et variés et qui vont nous
permettre justement de collecter de
nombreuses données en herbe sur la
surveillance ça va notamment permettre
d'essayer de répondre à des
problématiques de pêche illégale
des problématiques plus larges de
défense forcément puisqu'on va pouvoir
justement contrôler les trafics divers
et variés et puis finalement nous
permettent aussi de travailler et c'est
là tout l'intérêt de s'y promènent en
collaboration avec les acteurs du
domaine spatial
puisque aujourd'hui ces sujets là sont
principalement finalement on apporte des
solutions principalement via des acteurs
du domaine spatial
et nous on vient compléter ce qu'ils
collectent déjà par des satellites
spatiaux avec nos satellites de la mer
c'est vraiment ça l'idée donc ces
navires ont pour objectif à terme de se
déployer comme des constellations de
satellites de satellites spatiaux mais
sur les océans et la dernière je dirais
innovation chez citroën c'est un autre
modèle économique puisqu'on ne vend pas
les navires on vend la donne et qu'on
collecte et c'est là toute la différence
dans la façon dont on travaille avec nos
clients
ce qu'il ya de la valeur pour nos
clients c'est la donne et se sont pas
les navires eux mêmes
donc on change aussi la façon de
travailler nos clients et c'est ça aussi
qu'on essaye de faire évoluer dans
auprès de nos clients tous les jours
voilà et c'est vous qui concevait les
navires qu'elle était là on les conçoit
et on les opère tout à fait ces flottes
de navires et en effet la valeur c'est
la donnée qu'on collecte et comment
alors ce sont des navires autonome vous
avez dit des modes électrique et comme
beaucoup ils sont ravitaillés puisque
ces photos tel bonhomme qui resterait le
temps qu'il se recharge des batteries
des deux
alors on produit de l'énergie en fait
via des panneaux solaires via des
éoliennes aussi qui est qui mise à bord
on a une voile qui rigide qui nous
permet aussi d'aider à la propulsion et
puis lorsqu'on est en dérive en fait on
récupère de l'énergie en inversant tout
simplement le moteur électrique pour
recharger des batteries est donc cette
combinaison de production d'énergie nous
permet justement d'avoir sur des cycles
longs assez d'énergie pour la propulsion
des bateaux mais aussi pour la charge
utile qui est assez consommatrices
d'énergie vous c'est très intéressant
parce que
comme il n'ya pas de d'équipage à bord
vous pouvez intervenir dans des zones où
interviennent des pirates par exemple
pour aller surveiller leurs agissements
sans faire trop de risques le risque
humain et donc pour la surveillance
maritime c'est très intéressant
absolument c'est fabuleux
c'est le fabuleux ce qu'il faut bravo
bravo antoine thébaux et bravo à 6
problème donc pour l'instant où est-ce
qu'ils sont aussi tu veux pas vous
demander exactement mais vous travaillez
avec avec quelques ailes pays où quelque
chose aux prises vont dans quelle zone
travailler en méditerranée
aujourd'hui depuis en fait les premiers
avions ont été déployés en 2018 donc on
a travaillé principalement m'étonner là
on a eu notre mission qui va se lancer
en atlantique cet été justement donc
pour l'instant on travaille encore à
proximité on va dire de la métropole
mais l'objectif c'est d'aller aussi très
vite dans les territoires d'outre-mer
puisque ça fait partie forcément des
territoires qui ont besoin de cette
technologie est donc là on est en train
de travailler pour notamment à les
mettre des missions en place en guyane à
la réunion en nouvelle-calédonie en
polynésie
puisque c'est des territoires qui ont
besoin de ce genre de technologie dire
si vous courez bravo bravo emmanuel lévy
rester très concentré parce qu'on arrive
au 8e la huitième catégorie 8 et brice
et vous quel est le remède c'est la
catégorie management des effets
[Musique]
déjà la dernière catégorie jaoui
saperait les frites
will et ils sont tellement passionnant
qu'on en reste rait des les effets
dernier quels sont-ils ans donc ça peut
être cinétique
comme ce qui est relativement bien connu
mais ça peut être aussi du brouillage ou
des des armes à énergie dirigée comme
des lasers donc on est dans des systèmes
optroniques et donc gg de plaisir la dap
les dons d'entreprises gagnante qui est
si li na qui est sur un qui a proposé un
système d'imagerie haute résolution pour
des applications spatiales ou ou
aéroportée qui intègre une technologie
très très nouvel an de capteurs courbes
très nouvelle et très très transverse et
donc j'appelle donc pour nous en parler
un peu plus j'appelle wilfried yann
cofondateur et et michael bay hill on
aura même des deux roues il est là alors
c'est vous le ferez diam qui est avec
nous car il est un peu figé n'est pas
encore passée à la très haute résolution
oui c'est ça que vous avez recevait un
prix
une start up mais vous n'arrivez pas à
vous connecter
écoutez on va on va peut-être me taire
et attendre que la connexion soit un peu
meilleur peut-être bonjour non l'attend
pas encore peut-être on va peut-être
avancer un petit peu puis on reviendra
avec frais viande et que dès qu'il sera
avec nous on a vous avez remis ses huit
prix
en quoi consiste-t-il alors on va on va
dévoiler
en fait ces prix consiste en un
accompagnement avec des conventions de
développement qui vont être passés avec
ses entreprises
donc pour les accompagner sur deux ou
trois ans pour identifier des preuves de
concept réalisé avec eux et puis un
petit chèque qui va avec qui est un
chèque de 1000 euros
alors c'est pas énorme vous allez me
dire c'est essentiellement pour défrayer
les entreprises pour qu'elles puissent
venir physiquement pitcher sur nos sites
donc que ce soit le site des médias ou
celui d'un bus ça faisait un petit
chèque mais l'essentiel c'est ce qui se
passe après le mandat et donc quand on a
un lieu d'innovation sur le site d'el en
cours par exemple qui s'appelle le ilab
est donc ce qu'il avait fait pour
accueillir des start-up venir les faire
pitch est devant nos équipes échanger et
faire naître des idées parce que
l'entreprise a postulé avec une idée
préconçue
maintenant il faut qu'on puisse tester
que ça va s'adapter aux besoins d'airbus
ou des médias et donc démarrer dorée
projet en open innovation
donc c'est s'aider prix d'avenir si je
peux dire les deux et deux au fond de
collaboration notamment avec un bus et
une bd assez ça il faut identifier les
opportunités de développement et
travailler et ensuite se mettre en place
des travaux avec
des preuves de concept donc
démonstrateurs et puis ensuite on peut
franchir différentes étapes pour aller
vers des ce qu'on appelle les trn plus
élevés et des maturités de projets plus
élevés pour introduire les technologies
dans les produits définitif d'airbus ou
dvd
d'une façon générale qui a calé le le
sentiment que vous tirez de ceux de ce
cru de saint georges 2021
je vais pas vous surprendre c'est un
très bon cru oui on a des très belles
technologie très diverses avec des
sujets même assez nouveau on l'a vu mais
les robots les robots marin après des
sujets aussi qui consolide des tendances
qui étaient déjà là dans l'intelligence
artificielle des sujets aussi jeu pour
attirer votre attention là dessus sur
des sujets extrêmement complexe a été
dit par al sciemment sur des sur les
communications sur les radiofréquences
donc d'un côté céder sujet très complexe
et en même temps on vous renvoie des
petites structures extrêmement
performante et qui apporte des
innovations donc c'est on a voilà on a
ce bel ensemble je crois qu'on aura
votre wilfred liam 2 si l'ina vous nous
entendez alors peut-être vous pouvez
représenter évaluer les biens sont sous
leur présentation et sur leurs systèmes
d'imagerie haute résolution à base d'une
technologie de capteurs courbes et
c'était donc le prix de la catégorie
management des effets merci beaucoup
d'avoir sélectionné
non merci aux équipes de péquenots perdu
ses débuts à 6 li na est une forte perte
pour les clowns étaient fondées et qui a
pour but que de courber les capteurs
d'imagerie des systèmes de vision
actuelle et cela permet d'améliorer à la
fois les performances des capacités
défection dans la lisant la masse le
volume
de tous les systèmes de vision en fait
vous pouvez penser
on part d'un constat simple qui est que
la nature faune et légumes est constitué
d'une seule lentille cristalline et
d'une victime courbes et grâce à cette
petite courbe le lumen champ de vision
s'amuser et super fait tout un exploit
et quand vous regardez les systèmes de
vision actuelle et je vous ai tout un
plat de lentilles frais contexte fais et
ça c'est dû au fait que les capteurs
d'imagés actuelle cependant la semos
s'emploie à le payer d'apercevoir la
renaudié de compétition et de systèmes
optiques pour améliorer l'accueil et la
technologie des six mois permet deux
courbes et des capteurs traditionnels et
donc il se rapprocher consolante de la
mrc qui permet d'améliorer à la fois les
performances des quatre sélections tout
en réduisant la masse et de tous alors
aujourd'hui on est en phase le détroit
et los angles l'interaction crazy droite
avec airbus des pancakes et l'agencé
spatiale européenne pour mettre cette
technologie sur un tas de noms souvent
télévision
très bien on a un peu con compris ce
qu'était le capteur courbe
quand on connaît pas comme ça on se
demande ce que c est grâce
grâce à vous bravo bravo ou le frediani
et bravo à 6 li na donc d'avoir remporté
ce prix de la catégorie management des
effets vouliez ajouter quelque chose à
ce qu'est ce qu'ils veulent aider ou
technologique est très prometteuse on
imagine que les applications dans le
domaine des satellites ou même des
drones mais en fait tout et tout et
systèmes d'observation vont être très
très intéressante puisqu'on va améliorer
la résolution et augmenter les
performances de détection de ces
satellites de sedona les villes les 10
vous allez on revient sur ce cru 2021 à
la fois la fois une grande diversité et
la fois une grande inventivité une
grande créativité 1 16e c'est un peu ce
qu'on peut comme ça qu'on peut résumer
les différents des différentes
découvertes des start up qui ont été
primés oui tout à fait on n'arrête pas
les capacités d'innovation vous avez vu
en général ce sont des équipes plutôt
jeune avec des gens de haut potentiel de
très bonnes informations qui n'ont rien
à envier avec les ingénieurs que l'on
recrute chez airbus ou chez nvidia c'est
ce qui fait que ces startups peuvent
venir tout à fait concurrencer ce que
l'on peut faire dans nos grands groupes
au niveau technologique et apporter des
solutions innovantes avec lesquels on va
pouvoir travailler très rapidement
est-ce qu'ils étaient tout à fait
passionnant je trouve dans ce challenge
airbus nba c'est justement que vous de
montrer qu'il peut y avoir une
coopération entre ce que font ces
petites et toutes petites entreprises
parfois trois 3 personnes qui
travaillent chez eux sont très inventive
et puis les grandes structures comme
comme les vôtres
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas par foyer
des concurrences et va peut-être qu'on
est dans une nouvelle période où tout le
monde comprend qu'ils ont intérêt à
travailler ensemble quoi
une période qui peut être pas terminé
mais je pense que ça évolue où il y
avait de la prédation
oui c'est à dire que les grands groupes
racheter les start up et déposséder les
fondateurs de la propriété de leur
entreprise on n'est plus du tout dans ce
monde là et je pense qu on est beaucoup
plus dans un mode de coopération qui est
qu'ils aient bien compris c'est à dire
que on va accompagner la start up de
développer la technologie avec elle il à
faire grandir pour qu'elle puisse
devenir non pas une cible pour de
l'acquisition mais un partenaire pour
devenir un fournisseur de l'entreprise
et là il faut une maturité qui est qui
s'améliore et on a des dispositifs
achats qui ont été adaptés on a un
dispositif achats chez airbus ds qui
s'appelle start up to partenaires qui
est fait pour travailler avec les start
up avec des des procédures achat très
allégée au lieu d'avoir un pavé comme ça
vous avez quelques matches et ça permet
à la start up de postuler et on élimine
les critères éliminatoires liée à la
taille la matière et l entreprise
évidemment sinon on ne travaillerait pas
avec les startups et on s'est adapté et
on s'est adapté pour pouvoir travailler
beaucoup plus efficacement avec et puis
ce qu'on pourrait dire enfin c'est
pousser peut-être trop de cocorico
peut-être mais c'est vrai que il ya une
intelligence française une créativité
française qui sont tout à fait
remarquables
oui il faut voir à travers sa traversée
c'est tout ce qui nous pose dont on
parle de statut de start up nation je te
passerai la parole après les je crois
que l'inventivité n'a pas de limite dans
les startups ce qui limite que plus ce
sont les financements et c'est là où il
où en france on a encore quelques
progrès à faire pour aider ces
entreprises à se financer plus vite les
vivres on est convaincu qu'on a un
écosystème très innovant en france et on
est bien placé pour le pour le voir mais
c'est pour ça qu'on a ce cette politique
d'open innovation et qui est structuré
pas de manière similaire à ce qu'a dit
laurent donc je rejoins tout à fait
aussi sur ce ce type de structure qui
facilite des achats qui facilite aussi
la relation entre l'innovation les
achats et l'ingénierie des grands
groupes très bien m'écouter merci merci
infiniment
laurent legendre emmanuel lévy on pourra
retrouver évidemment tous ces gagnants
sur les sites des techno vais peut-être
sur d'autres sites se sait pas c'est
peut-être deux d'airbus ou non vus bien
sûr et puis surtout on va remercier
également tous les partenaires de teznaf
puisque c'est aujourd'hui le dernier
jour de tech'innove cesse à prolonger
après un mois un mois et donc tous les
partenaires si on peut passer à la slide
deux suivants
voilà notre partenaire industriel où de
nombreuses entreprises qui ont contribué
au succès de la première journée de
tech'innove qui a fait l'objet d'une
présentation dans ce même plateau
et puis pendant un mois des échanges qui
ont pu avoir lieu entre ces donneurs
d'ordres et puis toutes les entreprises
qui venaient ici présentées dans de
nombreuses filières leurs innovations à
ses donneurs d'ordre parfait merci
infiniment legendre et même les débits
et et bravo donc aux lui lauréats de ces
challenges airbus mbd à
[Musique]